a court in turkey has blocked internet
access to deutsche welle and voice of
america turkey wanted the broadcasters
to obtain a license in february dw did
not comply with a request out of concern
that it would allow the turkish
government to censor editorial content
dw director general peter limbuck has
pledged to take legal action against
this decision
now for more on that ban i'm joined by
the head of dw turkish
uh how did it come to this
yeah as you said in uh 219 um the
turkish court said or the turkish
lawmaker said that we definitely need a
license to broadcast in turkey
and we will not agree to this because we
think that as the director general said
that's kind of the door was open for
censorship from turkish government and
we didn't accept this in march i talked
to the president of the turkish
television and supreme council and he
said okay in that case we have to
investigate a little bit more and we'll
let you know but uh as you see they
plugged us out now so how can we respond
to this as how can dw respond to this
of course we didn't accept this and
we're trying to find solutions
how we can
use this for brighter media broadcasting
in turkey right now we're using the
social media platforms and uh of course
the response of dw is that we're really
uh
yes sad about this decision because as i
said the president of the supreme
council said that they will investigate
and they didn't
stand with their word to be honest let
me get this right our content on social
media like on facebook and twitter is
still accessible exactly
just dw.com is banned and unfortunately
we thought that they will ban just the
turkish program but now they banned the
whole edw dot com and which is not uh
appropriate uh any idea where how long
this will take um
when
users can access dw again well yet you
know the supreme council said that uh if
we apply immediately to a kind of
license then they will
open as soon as uh
they can but definitely dw will not
apply for such kind of license thank you
very much again arikan head of dw
turkish